[Music]
now this is a segment where viewers try
to find mistakes on our show okay I know
absurd right it's a flawless gem every
night that good luck viewers so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
no one has caught us making a mistake
well tonight a fan named Jason Forster
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened when I was talking recently to
actor Ellar Coltrane hey Conan found an
error in his show in the episode in
which you interviewed two Ellar Coltrane
from the movie boyhood you'd said that
the film had received eight Oscar
nominations you are part of this film
that has eight Oscar nominations
congratulations that's just absolutely
incredible you'd said that the film had
received eight Oscar nominations but in
fact it had only received six should
have checked IMDB before filming a show
[Music]
the first of all I'd like to
congratulate that gentleman he's the
first fan to send in a correction from
the distant future yeah where apparently
we don't have bodies anymore and we just
float in a black void dispensing useless
information we have no bodies or vocal
inflection no vocally I didn't see there
are you I'm from the future
I am from Duffy Oh ciao ciao ciao ciao
ciao well I'm sorry Jason
but you're dead wrong boyhood did get
eight Oscar nominations and if you had
watched Chris Pine in Academy president
Cheryl Boone Isaacs make the
announcement that morning you would know
the theory of everything and would lash
that concludes the regular nominations
now for the secret nomination all these
will be publicized they count every bit
as much as the regular nominations if
not more so for Best Picture that took
12 years to make and didn't they get
lucky no one died the nominees are
boyhood and that's all for Best
Performance by an actor going through
puberty on camera
the nominees are Ella - Coltrane in
boyhood just Ellar Coltrane in boyhood
Wow eight nominations for Boylan better
than six
[Music]
so the challenge still stands if you
think you have sported an era on our
show reported at team koco.com / haha I
found an error we will swore it out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chunk
meat out of the maestro
you